Nancy is with us in Fort Myers hey Nancy
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up good I
had a question about keeping or selling
my car I feel like I'm about to make an
emotional decision okay so I have a call
a car that's been recalled about nine
times in the past year and stupid tax I
bought it new I my husband and I are on
baby step two and I'm just wondering if
I need to suffer through it or if I
should get a smaller car with a smaller
loan I just I don't know what to do I
just I feel unsafe in this car okay
what's the nature of the recall so it's
one it's one of those first makes and
it's always something different anything
from airbags to seatbelt to technology
to what do things right it's a Jeep
Cherokee it was the first of its kind
three of the recalls have been this
month and I got the trade-in value and I
looked up Kelley Blue Book and they only
want to give me about thirteen five and
I owe 16 who you mean the trade-in value
is thirteen five yeah okay well you
wouldn't sell it for thirteen five
because that's that's wholesale and
you're not desperate you're just trying
to look at whether this is smart or not
okay the second so what would be the so
the private sale if you just put it on
the market on Craigslist more like 15
correct yeah so you only like a thousand
bucks in the hole there do you have any
money saved now we're on baby step two
side my little emergency fund but and
what's your household income we're at
160 okay and what's the other car in the
family my husband has another car it's a
charger that we owe 15 on and then we
have about ten thousand dollars in
credit card and medical debt okay all
right I do you like the cheap jerky
no you don't because of only because of
all the recalls or yeah I just
I hate coming back in all the time
taking time out of my workday and
everything else I'm just like shut up
with it but I don't want to roll it over
and well you don't know yeah you know
what you don't want to do is get just
like desperate seller mode that way that
would be emotional but if you just said
okay I don't like the car I'm gonna sell
the car for 15k put it on the market you
sell 15k you make 160 so let's scratch
up you know let's scratch up the
thousand bucks or 2000 bucks or whatever
your check you got to write go in pile
up some cash to get rid of it right
and that gets rid of the car now what
are we going to drive is the next thing
and as yours credit clean yes okay all
right so if you went down to the credit
union you could probably get a five or
six thousand dollar loan without any
trouble to to buy your next little car
right okay okay so do I'm separate don't
treat it know you trade it in the dealer
when they take a car in they want to
resell that car and make a profit right
and so they're gonna give you 13 mm-hmm
you're not desperate right you just are
mad
there's a difference you know there's
just there's just a difference I mean
don't don't get stupid just because
you're mad you know I mean just slow
down and $2,000 for the stupid here just
take your time let's just get the car on
the market get it sold and you know
somebody asks why you're selling it the
truth is there's been some been some
recalls on it and I'm wanting to get out
of that and that's a true statement to
the buyer if I'm standing there looking
at it and you know I'd most people do a
little bit of research on the car before
they buy it and I guess they'll find
what's going on that's kind of odd
actually because the Jeep Cherokee like
three years ago had one of the best
rankings in Consumer Reports as one of
the most reliable cars that's not the
Grand Cherokee yeah okay smaller okay
all right so I I don't know I don't know
I haven't tracked that and looked at it
but just I just was reading an article
and saw that on there I've never owned
one of them I mean we've got another
Jeep the little cj5 and the family
daniels got one but anyway the yeah just
sell it but don't give it away but
cause you're freaking out okay cover the
difference with cash and then go get
you'll alone by your five or six
thousand dollar car now here's the
emotional challenge are you really gonna
have a safer better car when you move
down $10,000 in car I know and this is
all under warranty I haven't had to come
out of pocket it's just an inconvenient
though so I don't think I don't think
you are only that cars that bad but I
could be wrong you you know I guess read
some articles on it and say are these
things really dangerous things or is
this just kind of been a pain in the
butt what if you didn't go in and get
the stuff repaired what happens well it
stalls out there's always bad okay so
it's having other thing we run even run
all right right oh crap yeah that that
does have eight you well I mean you just
don't whatever you do at the end of the
day I don't want you to have more debt
when the story is over
you if you don't move down to a seven
thousand dollar car and you move down to
a twelve thousand dollar car that's okay
it's not more debt it's less debt right
but don't don't call me back and go well
you know I was kind of mad about a
thirty two thousand dollar car you know
you know that that don't do that because
that's what we all have a tendency to do
because you make enough money and you've
got good credit it'll be real easy to
sign a piece of paper and walk out there
with a car you want that's how I got in
this mess in the first place
well it's it's a mess we all get in you
know and that's how you buy crap you
know these these cars and but you walk
in there though they'll make it feel
like it's painless and you'll walk out
like ten thousand dollars poorer when
the smoke clears on this and driving
something you really can't afford so
don't don't play into that let's just
get it sold take your time and it may
take you a couple months to sell it okay
and you know get it sold for a good
solid price don't be a motivated seller
just be a seller and get rid of the
thing and then you know during that time
if you guys can even want to push pause
on your debt snowball and pile up some
cash you make enough money while you're
selling this you might pile up six or
seven thousand bucks okay and um you
know then just pay cash for it and guess
what then we've got a net reduction of
debt of like fifteen grand right
only a nice move there and then in about
a year you're gonna move up in car again
probably because you're gonna clear out
the rest of these debts with this huge
income so okay you're heading in the
right the big thing here is just be
smart and intentional about it and make
steps that take you where you want to be
rather than just going oh I'll just sign
up for whatever you know because that's
what we all do we get aggravated and and
you've got the this economic ability to
sign stuff and they let you leave with
it you know and it just screws up our
lives all of us you know so that's what
you gotta fight against is it's just
real easy to walk in there and go we'll
just give me another one yeah get me one
that works and you know it just it's
gonna it's gonna make a bigger mess and
rather than a smaller mess so good
question thanks for calling in you can
do it you can do it this be very
intentional very calm very wise very
careful this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar in the company